we do have a lot more big news
considering medical professionals in
need Joe Biden took a pretty serious
fall
I felt kind of bad when I saw it he he
he fell straight to the ground it looked
bad for someone his age that could be
pretty serious they're saying he's fine
even Trump said I hope he's all right
and yeah I don't like the bidens I think
they're nasty people but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna laugh at it this is a sad
man when he runs up the stairs and he
trips we chuckle it's like ah he's like
because we know he's fine but this fall
on stage was really bad and I when I saw
that I was like oh man like we look like
broken hip or something like for real
not not funny I mean some people are
probably laughing at it